are you guys similar or polar opposites
I think you both so do you think that it
does it work a partnership where each
person is exactly like the other person
or you think each of you have your own
strengths maybe I weaknesses but things
that are maybe lacking that definitely
both of you make up for and that's why I
work so long yeah maybe for sure I think
in any relationship you if it's a it's a
good relationship you're relying on that
other person for to bring something to
the table that's not only going to allow
you to grow but they're bringing
something that is going to allow you to
allow them to grow as well so i think
this our relationship definitely shares
a lot of similarities but there are very
drastic differences as well creatively
you know it intellectually like you you
have very different interests than i do
and and and i mean all different I mean
I realize it's analyst i think yes we're
very different but we're very similar
and for whatever reason it worked out
very well for this film and we get along
very well which that's great it's good
to have on set but so how how did that
help on set goes like what are some
things that maybe you wouldn't always
get the job would like how would you
kind of I think begin yeah yeah I think
I'm very unrealistic especially with
with vision at times I think I'm a
deluded optimist so a real estat time so
i think i could say like okay what i'm
thinking is we're going to want this and
then they're gonna come in and even
though it might sound cool or to me
probably not to other people but Joe Joe
will listen entertaining that okay I
think I see where you're going this is
what realistically we can we can do
then okay and then he brings me back
down and then then you know I come up
with another need to go in there and are
within to work within those those
perimeters and parameters and and and
then it's just it's a mutual he brings
such a different type of creativity and
as do i and we're both I think very
responsible but also in very much like
having fun and I think that shows in the
soundtrack la actually going through and
not different styles in there and that's
kind of representative of that
difference I think yeah because we
improvise I mean we there are a couple
songs that were that weren't improvise
but other than that 90 yeah plus percent
of it majority the gross majority of the
film was improvised by Brandon Marshall
Ratched Joe and myself the soundtrack um
which was how much turned out great yeah
so for choosing a partner creative
partner if someone were to come to you
what would you say to them have have
known for years or even if you don't
what if you yeah it's got to be somebody
that you can be bluntly honest yeah you
cannot have somebody or you have to beat
around the bush I'll be like you're you
know you're full of you know this
is not going to happen right so um or
the opposite of that this is awesome or
we should do this tomorrow or you're
being crazy right now actually I think
that's that's a that reason right there
is the reason why we work so well
together is that we can be honest we can
say you're absolutely insane for
thinking what you're thinking or to try
and pull off what you're thinking and or
I think you're an idiot or you know
you're or whatever but not hurtful but
not hurtful but I mean we can say
whatever we want to say to each other
and we will move in a direction that
will ultimately provide some type of
resolve you both have to have a very
strong belief in a shared goal to I mean
obviously that's what you're looking for
to partner anyway but you know you have
to have an equal
out of gusto I guess for getting it done
mmm so not being afraid to hurt each
other's feelings me not trying to be
mean you can attacks full but you don't
I mean you be bluntly honest to you're
not trying to be malicious I'm not
saying somebody be malicious with other
day that but you have to be honest in a
situation like that where there's so
much at stake if you're not you're going
to be if you're gonna miss out
creatively or unprofessional yet I feel
everybody's really afraid of hurting
each other's feelings these days yeah
that's true and it's nice to be able to
just be plainly
you